the two lawyers who firebombed an nypd  police car in the blm protest last year  have reached a deal with prosecutors the  two attorneys at issue one of whom was  an associated very fancy new york law  firm have agreed to plead guilty to one  count of making or possessing a  destructive device that carries a  maximum term of 10 years in prison  though they probably won't receive  anything like that though it is possible  that the judge might use a terrorism  enhancement when deciding on the  sentence but still they're not going to  get 10 years they'll get less than that  and they will probably be disbarred for  being convicted of this felony crime so  just goes to show you you might agree  with someone's political stance but that  doesn't give you the right to use a  molotov cocktail to try and get your  desired result or we'll see you in court